we are very excited about our next guest
number one he's live and in studio we
like that tony and grammy award winner
david diggs is known for his performance
as lafayette and jefferson in the hit
broadway musical hamilton now he stars
in the dystopian thriller series it's
called snow piercer have you seen this
it's set in the year 2026
after an apocalyptic event freezes the
entire planet trapping survivors on a
moving train now in this clip from the
season three premiere dude's character
he plays a detective andre layton the
only homicide detective on board by the
way is getting ready for an expedition
outside the train
you know one time just for a change of
pain you could respect the chain of
command
chain of command
leighton this isn't a battleship it's a
bloody life raft and you're staying on
it
ben shouldn't even be out there he knew
what he was getting into yeah chasing
melanie's ghost her theory
we all agreed
we find new weed and then we go back to
the others what if there is no new eden
what she's wrong
david diggs joins us now in the studio
good morning we're so glad to have you
and liven in color and in person morning
going it's nice to be anywhere
it really is nice
so let's talk about this series because
number one i didn't know if so many
things could happen on a train number
one
you know it's it's such a classic story
of the haves and the have-nots it's
about race it's about betrayal it's
about are they going to get off of the
train how are they going to survive on
the train and you like the role why
uh
leighton's like um
he's always changing he's always
adapting to new information and that's
kind of what i like about him he's not
he should be a hero archetype right like
he should have only one mode but yes he
doesn't he's constantly sort of taking
information and like
apologizing and like you know like he's
sort of like
uh has all the all the toxic masculinity
traits but he's actively trying to
combat them i think which is well
they're useful in the in the environment
yeah yeah were you familiar with the
story already before you did the series
yeah well i had seen the film you had it
okay it's done so so yeah which is which
is brilliant and is did really a lot of
the heavy lifting or at least of the
it created the world that we get to play
in right the the tv show takes on a very
different a lot of different turns and
has moved on to to a lot of different
places than than bong joon-ho's
brilliant film meant to go but
um but how about the irony though of
shooting this during a pandemic isolated
on a train when many of us in our lives
are isolated not on a train but very
much isolated yeah it was a trip you
know we we shut down in the middle of
shooting season two and then had to come
back and figure out how to shoot while
sort of in the height of the pandemic so
that was when we were first getting used
to wearing masks and stuff and and um
it really hit home it was it was also
you know the the kind of isolation that
you must feel being the last of of
only a few thousand people left on earth
is like it it definitely amplifies stuck
on a thousand car long trains yeah yeah
right yeah one minor other one
how do you think you would handle
yourself in a real 2026 is not that that
far in the future if we all end up on a
train how would you do i love trains
actually uh but if it's like this one i
don't want to be on it
and although you get to survive at least
yeah in a sense it might be worth it i
don't know
also leighton's like from the tail i
need my first class
i've gotten soft hands you know i can't
be
i have to ask you about one of the other
things i was so thrilled i think people
of a certain age fraggle rock you get to
be a part of fraggle you have no idea
how much i freaked out when i got that
offer i was why why i was such a fraggle
rock fan growing up um
and i can't i can't i can't give too
much away about who i'm playing or
anything but like it's it was it was a
dream and that the hanson companies just
when opportunities like that come your
way you talk about it just being a dream
what is it like to start living out
maybe even a dream that you didn't see
uh
it's it's pretty cool you know i mean
i'm i'm at a a point in my life where
i'm getting to do like a lot of cool
things it's a lot i have a lot of pinch
myself moments really like all the time
i mean i'm here you know i watch you
guys too now we're sitting on like we
having a normal ass conversation but
yeah yeah what's it like for you to be
sitting here with us
let's talk about that it's still it's
still weird yeah i know
it's so weird to see people you know we
were having a conversation about you
before you came because we've all seen
hamilton i've seen you in that role five
times and from the moment you come on
the stage it's just instant applause
before you even open your mouth and then
you take those steps
before you even say anything and we were
having a debate about i wonder if he's
sick of talking about it i wonder if it
gets old to him because you know we
played the song and we all sort of
laughed and smiled and then disney
opened it up to the world yeah do you go
oh god here it is yeah well
i i think less now than i used to
because i don't i don't come in contact
with it every day anymore and i don't
watch it and i don't you know so it used
to be like when i was living in new york
and we were doing it and it was playing
on everyone's stereo and and that was
that was actually the hardest time but
when you said it was weird being here
you weren't referring to the pandemic
you were talking about how it still
feels like a quick journey from where
you were pre-handled into now yeah i
don't know why y'all want to talk to me
but i'm happy you do like you know um
yeah it's have you looked at your resume
sir i
that my ten-year-old step son has
actually been impressed
[Laughter]
take that for one no no i'm doing big
things with the ten-year-old set i know
we're really targeting that demographic
with all with all actually
but do you marvel though that you've
gone from where you've come from to
doing what you're doing do you
uh work to get here the
miraculous part to me is that
in large part i mostly work with my
friends who i've been working with
forever still and that that's really
special for me um we're we're also
starting production on season two of
blind spotting right which is like a
tv show that me and rafael
made up in our heads yes a decade ago so
we're you know and
jasmine stevens jones from hamilton is
the star of it and you know our friend
helen hunt is it like it's all it's like
there's family everywhere you have
family in so many of your projects real
quickly it's almost like family can i
you can give a shout out to your 49ers
bang bang niner gang man congrat
congratulations
you're a sport you're you do sports as
well so you're interested in sports i
want to ask about the cookies there's a
video of you giving a tour of your house
and your wife is ragging on you for
eating cookies in the bedroom what a
great house too what a great house
you're not allowed to eat no eddie so
you eat them on the floor i move on to
the floor what are these cookies
i'm a guy this i'm uh i i don't
discriminate when it comes to it
all
every and all cookies
thank you so much for being with us
really a pleasure for more than just the
10 year old set
for all of us exactly and the new season
of snow piercer premieres next monday
that's on tnt